[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
da sind wir wieder mit einem spannenden
Fall ich bin Mirko Kasimir und ich freue
mich dass ich heute Natalie Strauß an
meiner Seite habe Mirko das Brot
natürlich auf gegenseitigkeiten und
heute haben wir eine Geschichte die hat
von allem zu viel eine schöne Frau
Reichtum Sex Lügen Schüsse Aufregung
Justiz Irrtümer und vielleicht sogar
Geheimdienst Schmutz und eine
Waffenhandel connection ja das klingt
nach einem spannenden Krimi würde ich
sagen der Fall wurde übrigens benannt
nach der angeblichen Täterin und die
heißt Vera grüner bevor wir mehr über
sie erfahren schauen wir uns die gute
erstmal an Vera grünes sieht in den
1960er Jahren aus wie eine
Ü 50 Traumfrau vieler deutscher sie
trägt ihr Stroh blondes gelocktes Haar
meist offen es schlank und sportlich sie
hat große wache Augen eine wohlgeformte
Nase und ein Vollmond Vera Brühne kann
mitreißend humorvoll gucken aber auch
dramatisch Ernst jetzt aber Schluss mit
den Äußerlichkeiten
[Musik]
Vera wird am 6 februar 1910 als Vera
Maria Kohlen in Essen geboren ihr Vater
Ludwig Kohlen ist Bürgermeister des
Ortes von kraileite der später ein
Stadtteil von Essen wird ihre beiden
Brüder studieren Jura wäre dagegen darf
nur eine Haushaltsschule besuchen boah
wow die gute alte Zeit ja leider die
schlechte nicht gerade frauenfreundliche
Zeit geprägt von verstaubten
Rollenbildern naja zurück zum Fall Vera
Kohlen heiratet 1937 den Schauspieler
Hans Kossi bürgerlich lautet der
Nachname übrigens cosiolkowski den
müssen wir uns für später merken
1941 kommt Tochter Silvia zur Welt und
1943 sorgte Krieg für eine erste
dramatische Wendung in Veras Leben ihr
Mann hat den Handwerker Johann fehrbach
auf das Grundstück der Familie bestellt
weil dort ein Luftschutzbunker gebaut
werden soll bei einem Bombenangriff wird
zerstört verbach rettet Vera und ihre
Tochter und nimmt sie bei sich zu Hause
auf schon in dieser Zeit leben Vera und
fehrbach offenbar für eine Weile in
einer Art Beziehung aber ihre Ehe mit
Cossy alias kosiolkowski wird erst 1953
geschieden Vera zieht in der
Zwischenzeit nach München hält aber
Kontakt zu verbach sie heiratet den
Handwerker aber nicht sondern den
Filmkomponisten Lothar Brünner ich kann
mir das ein Stück weit vorstellen ich
meine wenn du nur zur Haushaltsschule
gehen darfst dann achtest du natürlich
darauf dir einen wohlhabenden Mann zu
angeln der grüne ist übrigens auch nur
ein Jahr nach der Scheidung von Vera mit
58 Jahren gestorben im Jahr ihre
Scheidung kommt es für Vera grüne zu
einer schicksalhaften Begegnung sie
besitzt mehrere Eigentumswohnungen in
einer davon in München Schwabing wohnt
sie selbst schließlich kommt sie aus
einer gutbürgerlichen Familie und
verfügt über die gerichtlich getrennten
Mittel aus zwei Scheidungen aber
trotzdem muss regelmäßig Geld in die
Kasse im spießigen Vokabular der 50er
und 60er sagt man wohl sie bietet sich
wohlhabenden Herren als Begleitung an
dass das gut funktioniert zeigt die
schicksalhafte Begegnung die Mirko
angekündigt hat im Sommer 1957 kommt sie
in einer Gaststätte mit dem geschiedenen
Gynäkologen dr Otto Braun ins Gespräch
der Mann ist 16 Jahre älter als sie
begleitet wird er an diesem Abend von
Elfriede Klo sie ist 46 Jahre alt und
führt seinen Haushalt und nach allem was
später ermittelt wird ist sie auch seine
Partnerin schon hier fängt es mit den
etwas sehr schrägen menschlichen
Beziehung an denn Elfriede klug verlässt
das Lokal während Frauen und wäre sich
prächtig unterhalten da entsteht eine
Arzt Dreieck oder sogar Viereck wir
versuchen das jetzt mal so ein bisschen
auseinander zu tröseln Frauen überlässt
Vera grüne einen gebrauchten VW Käfer
und er bittet sie ihm an zwei Abenden in
der Woche zur zu stehen angeblich nur
als Fahrerin dafür bekommt Vera 200
Marke Monat man muss dazu sagen dass
dieser dr braun für damalige
Verhältnisse stinkreich sein muss der
Mann betreibt eine kassenarztpraxis in
München und hat eine Villa in Pöcking am
Starnberger See außerdem gehören in zwei
Mietshäuser in München und eine Finca in
Spanien läuft bei ihm und wie du schon
richtig sagtest dass Beziehungsgeflecht
ist sehr spannend denn auch mit der
Verwalterin dieses spanischen Besitzes
in Lloret de Mar hat braun offenbar eine
Beziehung laufen die Frau heißt Katja
Hinze und braun hat sie als Erben der
Finger in seinem Testament festgelegt
wie sich später zeigt besitzt Frauen
auch Schusswaffen er soll nie ohne aus
dem Haus gegangen sein man könnte
übrigens einen eigenen Podcast über
diesen Ort machen er kam aus einer
Familie von Geheimdienstlern der
Nazizeit Frauen selbst arbeitete in der
NS-Diktatur als Arzt für die Allianz
Versicherung
da soll er ein Ehepaar mit gefälschten
Attesten vor der Zwangsarbeit gerettet
haben da gibt es sogar noch ein
spannendes Nebengleis Frauen war mit der
früheren Geheimagentin Sonja
blättschacher befreundet sie wurde 1954
tot mit einer Schusswunde aufgefunden
die Polizei legte den Todesfall aber
später als Suizid zu den Akten wie
bereits am Anfang angekündigt in dieser
Geschichte gibt es von allem zu viel vor
allem zu viele enge Beziehungen und das
bedeutet eine Menge Streitpotenzial Ende
der 50er Jahre hält Otto Braun offenbar
immer größere Stücke auf die schöne
verabrehne im Oktober 57 fährt er mit
ihr zur Finca in Lloret de Mar und im
Jahr darauf feiert ihr Katja hinter als
Verwalterin und streicht sie aus dem
Testament neue Erben Vera grüne das
ganze Beziehung durcheinander ins weit
die Familie Braun Weihnachten 1959
zerstreiten sich Otto Braun und seinen
damals 29-jähriger Sohn Günther der in
München ebenfalls als Arzt arbeitet von
ihm werden wir noch hören wir sind jetzt
im Jahr 1960 Frauen entschließt sich die
Finca in Spanien zu verkaufen aber dazu
kommt es erst gar nicht Anfang 1960
zeigt sich auch in Vera grünes Leben
spielt immer noch Johann Ferbach eine
Rolle wir erinnern uns das ist ihr
Retter aus dem Krieg die beiden sind
Ende Februar zusammen beim Karneval in
Köln Natalie bevor wir zum April 1960
kommen lassen wir das Gemälde noch mal
auf uns wirken wir haben den Reichen
Arzt Dr braun der ist kürzlich seine
Geliebte und Erben Katja Hinze in die
Wüste geschickt hat er hat aber noch
eine enge Beziehung zu seiner
Haushälterin Elfriede und zu seiner
angeblichen Chauffeurin Vera die
wiederum immer noch Kontakt zu ihrem
langjährigen Gefährten Johann Held nicht
vergessen sollten wir in dieser
Aufzählung die Kinder wäre es Tochter
silviakowski ist gerade 19 Jahre alt und
macht sich in München als Partygirl den
Namen Brauns Sohn Günther arbeitet als
Assistenzarzt in der Stadt und hat sich
gerade erst mit dem Vater überworfen im
April 1960 ist Vera viel unterwegs unter
anderem besucht sie vom 8 bis 13.4 ihre
Mutter in Bonn die ist ebenso krank wie
damals gerade ihr dauerbekannter Johann
verbach den sie am 13 April in Köln
besucht all diese Daten werden später
aus guten Grund festgehalten auch das
Vera grüne am 14 April aus NRW nach
München zurückkehrt und dort ein Auto
abholt das Braun für Sie geordert hat
mit April stimmt etwas nicht rund um die
Braunsche Villa in Pöcking das fällt dem
Arbeiter Uli Schauer auf der sich um den
Garten kümmert und ist alarmiert Brauns
Sprechstundenhilfe Renate Meier und
ihren Freund Hans-joachim Vogel
heute möchten wir euch Wolfskinder das
Thriller die von Autorin Vera book
vorstellen er Schienen ist das Buch beim
Robert Verlag in dem Buch verschwinden
immer wieder Frauen in einem
abgeschiedenen Ort in den Bergen einer
Siedlung fernab von der modernen Welt
hier gelten die Regeln der Natur rau und
erbarmungslos nun möchte die junge
Journalistin Smilla die vor Jahren ihre
Freundin juli in der Gegend verloren hat
der Wahrheit auf die Spur kommen erst
recht als ihr ein verwahrlostes Mädchen
vors Auto läuft das verblüffende
Ähnlichkeit mit Julia hat und schon bald
kommt Smilla einem schockierenden
Geheimnis auf die Spur das alle
vermeintlichen Wahrheiten aus den Angeln
hebt wo lauert das Böse wirklich mit
großer Sprachkraft und psychologischer
Tiefe erzählt Vera Bug von menschlichen
Abgründen erzählt ist das Buch aus sechs
Perspektiven und bildet durch das
Atmosphäre bedrohliche bergsetting die
perfekte abgeschiedene Kulisse für
diesen furiosen Thriller also große
Leseempfehlung für Wolfskinder von Vera
Buck
Werbung Ende
weil sie Frauen nicht ans Telefon
kriegen fahren Sie nach Starnberg Renate
Meier und Hans-joachim Vogel melden sich
am 19 April
1960 spät abends um 23 Uhr bei der
Polizei in felderfingen weil bei ihrem
Kontrollbesuch in Pöcking jemand
aufgemacht hat zwei Streifenbeamte
fahren zur Villa und öffnen Sie sofort
stoßen sie auf die Leiche von Braun der
mit einer Schusswunde an der Schläfe an
der Heizung in der Diele liegt ein
Inspektor der später dazu stößt findet
im Keller schließlich auch die Leiche
von Elfriede Klo auch sie weiß eine
eintrittswunde auf und zwar am Genick
wenige Tage später sind Justiz und
Gerichtsmedizin bereit den Fall zu den
Akten zu legen offenbar hat Dr braun
erst Elfriede erschossen und dann sich
selbst nennt man erweiterter Suizid im
Amts Deutsch der Fall und beide Toten
werden begraben aber beide werden
wiederkommen denn Sohn Günther braun
will die Geschichte vom Selbstmord nicht
wahrhaben erst recht nicht als Lehrer
das Haus in Lloret de Mar erben soll
Günther erwirkt bei der
Staatsanwaltschaft die Wiederaufnahme
der Ermittlungen und die Exhumierung der
Leichen bei der Autopsie der Leiche von
Braun stellt sich heraus er hat zwei
Schusswunden am Kopf kann sich also gar
nicht selbst getötet haben und so werden
Vera grüne und Johann Ferbach im Oktober
1961 verhaftet 25 April 1962 vor dem
Landgericht München 2 beginnt der
Prozess wegen der vielen Schaulustigen
und Fotografen bricht in der Umgebung
der Verkehr zusammen den Vorsitz hat ein
Doktor Klaus Seibert insgesamt werden
drei Berufsrichter und sechs line über
den fallurteilen und schon vor der
ersten Anhörung sieht es nicht gut aus
für Vera grüner da ist dieser unfassbare
Körper mit ihrer Tochter Silvia die war
zum Tatzeitpunkt in England sie
behauptet aber noch vor Prozessbeginn
gegenüber Reportern und der Polizei das
wäre ihr gegenüber dem gut gestanden hat
genauer gesagt dass Sie Johann fehrbach
das zugebracht habe Otto Braun und
Elfriede Klo zu erschießen fehrbach
wiederum wird von einem Häftling namens
Siegfried Schramm belastet mit dem er in
U-Haft saß Schramm sagt fehrbach habe
ihm gegenüber mit dem Mord in Pöcking
geparkt im Prozess nimmt immerhin verast
Tochter Silvia ihre Aussage zurück aber
schwerwiegen die Geschichten die Brauns
Sohn Günther und Sprechstundenhilfe
Renate Meier bei steuern die beteuert
verbach habe sich am Tag Zutritt zur
Villa verschafft weil er sich als
Kaufinteressent für die Finke in Spanien
ausgab diese Version soll auch ein
getippter briefstützen den Sohn Günther
als Beweisstück präsentiert das
Schreiben war angeblich von Braun an
Elfriede gerichtet und kündigte den
Besuch eines Herrn Dr Schmitz an das
muss man vielleicht so erklären laut
Sohn Günther wollte Vera grüne ihrem
Freund Johann Zugang zu Frauen
verschaffen deshalb kündigte sie ihn als
Kaufinteressenten dr Schmitz an nach
Pöcking kommen würde das Gericht hält am
Ende folgendes für die Wahrheit Vera
Brüne und Johann fehrbach verschafften
sich am 14 April 1960 mit der Geschichte
vom geplanten Hauskauf Zugang zur Villa
in Pöcking und erschießen Otto Braun und
Elfriede Clou
Todeszeitpunkt Brauns sei folglich der
gleiche Tag um 19:45 Uhr gewesen die
Angeklagten werden am 4 juni 1962 wegen
gemeinschaftlichen Doppelmordes zu
lebenslange Haft verurteilt ein
Fehlurteil zumindest ein Urteil das
heute niemand mehr so in Deutschland
Fällen würde da waren sich Jahre später
eigentlich alle einig dafür gibt es auch
viele gute Gründe und der stärkste ist
der Todeszeitpunkt die Gerichtsmedizin
und das Gericht legen sich auf den Abend
des 14 aprilfest spätere Überprüfung
ergaben aber den 20 April da war Vera
grüner aber gar nicht im Raum München
sondern von Zeugen bestätigt im Bonn
auch der angeblich bei den Toten
gefundene Brief auf blaues Papier
getippt war darf als zweifelhaft gelten
das Schreiben hatten keinesfalls
Polizisten am Tatort gefunden sondern
Sohn Günther überreichte es dem Gericht
ja das ist übrigens auch der gleiche
Günther der an Vera Stelle die Finca in
Lorette der Fall wäre Brüne hat also
Rechtsgeschichte geschrieben weil er so
schlampig verhandelt wurde aber neu
aufgenommen wurde er trotz allem nicht
viel mehr wurde Vera grüne nach 18
Jahren Haft im Jahr 1979 vom bayerischen
Ministerpräsidenten Strauß begnadigt sie
zog danach in ihre alte Wohnung zurück
sie starb 2001 im Krankenhaus immerhin
im Alter von 91 Jahren aber Mirko wenn
man mal annehmen dass sie unschuldig war
wer war es dann
tja Natalie weil braun so eine
schillernde Figur war gibt es da so
einige Theorien zum Beispiel soll er in
illegalen Waffenhandel verwickelt
gewesen sein und machte sich so
vielleicht Feinde braun wurde zum
Beispiel mit einem Bestechungsskandalen
Verbindung gebracht bei dem es um
Schützenpanzer ging und einer der
Akteure dabei war ein gewisser Werner
reppening und rate mal wessen
persönliche Referent der war
keine Ahnung ja er war die rechte Hand
von Franz Josef Strauß also dem
Ministerpräsidenten der Vera grüne
begnadigt hat puh also hatte der
vielleicht ein schlechtes Gewissen kann
es sein ja wer weiß das schon alle die
was dazu sagen könnten sind längst tot
[Musik]
das ist echt ein krasser Fall mit vielen
Zutaten zu vielen um ehrlich zu sein wir
haben ihn erzählt mit den Einträgen aus
dem Fall Archiv des Axel Springer
Verlages sowie mit älteren Artikeln der
Abendzeitung und ist Michael Merkurs
gute Orientierung bietet auch die
Chronik die der Online Ritzen sind die
da wunderlich zusammengestellt hat Links
dazu gibt's natürlich in dem Show Notes
Aufnahme und Script Stefan Netzeband
Schnitt Antonia Heier fußproduktion
durch die weight watch Studios München
bis bald euer Mirko vielen Dank dass ihr
dabei wart eure Natalie
und dieses Mal haben wir ganz am Ende
auch noch eine Einzelheit sozusagen als
Hidden Track ein unfassbares Detail
Mirko am Morgen nach dem laichenfund in
Pöcking war der Dackel von Otto Braun
gefunden worden jemand wahrscheinlich
der oder die Mörder hatten ihn in einem
Kellerraum weggesperrt und der Kommissar
der am nächsten Morgen eintraf der
erschoss den armen Hund und ließ ihn auf
dem Gelände begraben
das ist unfassbar ich würde sagen
vielleicht hätte der Hund noch
irgendwelche Beweisstücke gehabt
schreiben
[Musik]